hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm Kat Alvarado I got my comedian
friend with me today to do it try not to
laugh cuz comedians are always like
that's not funny I know funny guys
that's me all the time all the time
morning noon night Kat before we go into
this try not to laugh tell them about
your podcast which I guess are wrong
it's called villains of History and it's
about all the worst people from history
it's pretty fun he was in the first
episode he popped my podcast cherry
[Laughter]
they're they're pretty funny should
watch them you know I've noticed I've
actually Seth MacFarlane included I
noticed a lot of comedians are obsessed
with history a lot of comedians you can
learn so much from history for example a
Caligula and Nero or both very annoying
friends who'd make their friends listen
to their jokes and songs that's like the
worst right
yeah I hate being told to listen to
stuff speaking of which put those
headphones on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love you [ __ ] off
[Music]
oh my god again
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no oh no oh no oh that's not funny
just wrong oh my god Wow oh my god
two-time variety of emotions I feel bad
for some reason me feeling bad was
making it funnier than me I felt like a
deer accumbens in my eyes were just
laughing really tried to cuz now I feel
like if I laugh it's gonna offend you
for some reason so much I'm really
trying hard not to laugh oh man I was
you know that was that was easily the
hardest try not to laugh moment I think
I've ever had oh god I'm sorry I do not
realize like empathy for you or
something funny it looks like a real not
even real I just love the another word
for it just the enhancement of the joke
of just how it just keep going with it
and oh man to falling down the bit
stairs right I thought he was gonna stop
I was like okay three threes yeah honey
it takes us happiness it's like whole
flip to it it's like you know it's
coming but it what's funny is like you
don't know the action that it's gonna
turn into it's not he just slips and
falls like it's crazy like whip into
this physical comedy about this might be
my favorite of the family guys that I've
seen so far they try not to laugh this
might be my favorite I was a big fan of
gorilla door or just that opening bit of
like white guys being afraid to tell
like a group of black people like oh
your city that other side of racism
where you're not going to attack but
instead the races side comes in because
you're just scared of them so instead
you back down you're so scared you're
scared of offending them so that you
just end up at the same place yeah
version of this is funny yes it was and
I'm so sorry about that whale
but man that had that had me dying oh my
gosh how much more you can say subscribe
to the rejects click that notification
bell
cat Alvarado check out her podcasts
villains of history it's funny it's
funny do it today I'll see you guys
later
hi